this scary man with a bass can we just
clarify he is paying you to do this it
is one of you behind the shouting
finally saying that yeah just just like
there are some things I don't want
telling my age 15 you know in the style
of will Anderson's hair the size was
trimmed okay
cool lovely you started off I got a lot
of fuss I go down into the ocean meet up
with the cockta puss that is the name is
a portmanteau you gotta watch out for
the eight digs down below in fact he
would have nine one on each leg and one
at the bottom by the mounts in his head
so let me say this I believe to y'all
we know the [ __ ] is already on the
tentacle isn't that the truth like a
starfish penis it comes up to you we've
all seen this far penises like it's a
handprint I see it over there and I
really do think when I'm in the ocean
swimming after dark I watch out for a
little fin of a shark but then I like
run away chills running some stuff but
then I realize it's will and the Sun so
it's down there coming through the ocean
portal going underwater cuz he's using
an Oracle he got his goggles yeah he got
his flippers when he starts chasing you
he's gonna beat you he gonna bash it has
an inch up off your genitals I don't
know in your mouth if they're that small
or maybe if it's larger like they're
eight feet get it in the imperial system
really it won't fit in I have a look I
want some peace so I get a coloring book
and I turn the page but alas every
single page is the [ __ ] of I'm gonna
use up all on the crayons I'm trying to
draw a reindeer and I display one arm in
a fridge here on the refrigerator but my
parents don't like it cuz they are not
to push Hado they'd be like no son from
me will give me a picture of the takla
Mari even I can a kid getting it out
with the penis squid awkward and work
those two together for a pond but either
way it's being so damn fun something I
put my brain at rest
octopus and we'll Anderson is best for
mindfulness yeah
that's great plunge it drop the plunger